.
HE PLEADED NOT GUILTY AND IS
FREE ON BOND.
>>> THE SUSPECT IN THE DEADLY
SHOOTING IN BOULDER, COLORADO,
HAS BEEN IN COURT FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
AHMAD ALISSA WAS BROUGHT INTO
COURT IN A WHEELCHAIR AND SPOKE
ONLY ONCE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CHARGES.
HE DEFENSE ATTORNEY IMMEDIATELY
REQUESTED A MENTAL HEALTH
EVALUATION.
NOW COMES AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT
THE TEN VICTIMS OF THAT ATTACK
INCLUDING 61-YEAR-OLD KEVIN
MAHONE.
HE WAS A FATHER OF TWO.
HIS DAUGHTER ERIKA HAS SHARED
THIS PHOTO.
OUR LEAD NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
SPOKE TO THE MAHONEYs IN
BOULDER.
>> Reporter: THIS IS HOW THE
WORLD FIRST FOUND OUT THAT KEVIN
MAHONEY WAS KILLED -- WHEN HIS
DAUGHTER ERIKA POSTED THIS PHOTO
THAT'S GONE VIRAL SAYING, "MY
DAD REPRESENTS ALL THINGS LOVE.
I'M SO THANKFUL HE COULD WALK ME
DOWN THE AISLE."
>> THAT EXPRESSION THAT HE HAD
ON HIS FACE IS WHAT I'VE SEEN MY
WHOLE LIFE THAT REPRESENTS SO
MUCH PRIDE BUT ALSO HOLDING BACK
TEARS.
>> Reporter: WHY DID YOU PICK
THAT PHOTO?
>> WE KNEW HE WAS GONE, BUT IF
THERE WAS A MOMENT I COULD SHARE
WITH THE WORLD THAT CAPTURED WHO
HE WAS AND ALSO MY RELATIONSHIP
WITH HIM, IT WAS THAT MOMENT.
>> Reporter: HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE YOUR HUDSBAND'S LOVE FR
YOUR DAUGHTER?
>> KEVIN IS A SWEET SOUL.
AT THAT MOMENT IN TIME, HE
EMBRACED THE FEELINGS, AND IT
REFLECTED IN HIS FACE TOWARD HIS
DAUGHTER.
HE LOVED TO SKI.
HE LOVED TO HIKE.
HE LOVED TO CAMP.
HE LOVED TO TRAVEL.
>> Reporter: AT THE TIME ERIKA
ANNOUNCED HER FATHER'S DEATH,
SHE REVEALED THAT SHE WAS
PREGNANT WITH THE FIRST
GRANDCHILD OF THE FAMILY.
>> THIS LITTLE BABY GIRL IS
WHAT'S GETTING US THROUGH THIS
TIME BECAUSE LIKE I CAN FEEL HER
KICK, AND EVERY KICK IS TELLING
ME TO BE STRONG.
AND OF COURSE MY DAD EVEN THOUGH
THIS IS SO DEVASTATING AND SO
HURTFUL, HE WANTS US TO CARRY
ON.
>> Reporter: KEVIN MAHONEY IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE AND
DAUGHTER AND ONE SON.
KEVIN WE'RE TOLD WAS DOING THE
SHOPPING FOR THE FAMILY.
HE DIDN'T WANT HIS WIFE TO HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT DOING IT IN THE
MIDDLE OF PANDEMIC, SO HE'D DO
IT ALL THE TIME.
HE WAS SHOPPING RIGHT OVER THIS
FENCE, DOING WHAT WE ALL DO IN
AMERICA, WE DON'T THINK TWICE,
WE GO SHOPPING, AND HE DIED
DOING IT.
>> WE NEVER THINK TWICE ABOUT
IT.
THAT'S WHY THIS IS SO HARD.
I HEARD STORIES ABOUT SOMEONE
JUST GOING TO BUY MUSHROOMS.
EVERY TIME I LOOK AT THE MAHONEY
PICTURE I'M STRUCK AT ERIKA'S
EXPRESSION, THE WAY SHE'S
LOOKING AT HER DAD.
HONESTLY, IT GETS ME EVERY TIME
I SEE IT.
THEN YOU LOOK AT HER FACE AND
THEN YOU LOOK AT HIS.
AND YOU CAN SEE THE BOND BETWEEN
THE TWO OF THEM.
IT'S A LOT.
AND TO KNOW THAT NOW A
GRANDDAUGHTER IS COMING, I'M SO
GLAD THAT THAT IS STILL GOING TO
PROCEED IN THEIR LIFE.
THIS IS VERY TOUGH, DAVID.
VERY TOUGH.
>> Reporter: THEY WANTED TO